[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this week, I'm
at the Launchpad
Space in San Francisco.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
This week, we introduced
YouTube-BoundingBoxes,
a dataset consisting of five
million bounding boxes spanning
23 object categories,
densely labeling segments
from 210,000 YouTube videos.
To date, this is the largest
manually annotated video
dataset containing
bounding boxes
which track objects in
temporally contiguous frames.
To get started with
this data to train
your own large-scale models,
take a look at the post linked
in the description below.
For the tech industry
to thrive and create
groundbreaking technology that
supports the global ecosystem,
it is critical to
increase the diversity
and inclusion of communities
that make the technology.
To help with that, Women
Techmakers recently
partnered with Change Catalyst
to develop some resources
on how to build inclusive
technology hubs.
If you're part of an incubator,
community organization,
accelerator, or coworking
space, please head
on over to the post for links
to the videos and how-to guides.
Chrome 57 Beta is now
available with CSS grid
layout, improved Add to
Homescreen, media session
API, and more.
All the details are on the post.
By the way, for you progressive
web app enthusiasts,
over the next few weeks,
that Add to Home experience
in Chrome Beta will integrate
into Android in a much deeper
way than before.
Progressive web
apps will now appear
in the app drawer
section of the launcher
and in Android settings.
It will be able to
receive incoming attempts
from other apps and more.
Details and screenshots
are on the post.
We recently announced two new
Firebase Admin SDK features.
The Node.js SDK now
contains an Admin API
for sending messages via
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
and the Java SDK can
now be initialized
from a set of
built-in credentials,
making it easier
to use, especially
on Google infrastructure.
Details and code
are on the post.
Oh, and if you've got questions
about debugging Firebase Cloud
Messaging on IOS,
this post is for you.
It's a full debugging guide
with a video and code.
Pre-configured images from
Microsoft SQL Server Enterprise
and Windows Server Core are now
available on Compute Engine.
High availability
and disaster recovery
are top of mind for
our large customers,
so we're also announcing
support for SQL Server,
always-on availability groups,
and persistent disk snapshots
integrated with Volume Shadow
Copy Service on Windows Server.
To learn more and
get started today,
head on over to the post.
We also have new code labs for
running Windows and .NET apps
on Google Cloud Platform with
their own dedicated page.
For the link and an overview
to help you get started,
head on over to the post linked
in the description below.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, thanks for watching this
week's episode at the Launchpad
Space in San Francisco.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
click on the links to my left.